I think the show is going so far oh
great the crowd really seems to love it
yeah that last comedy bit was the zero
you asked for a zero no yeah I have zero
energy tonight you back spray zero uh no
thanks kind of chilly out here sure hope
it doesn't get down to zero you asked
for a zero no hey I finally got that
World War two model airplane that I
ordered you know the Japanese zero this
no no I didn't thank you you know I
learned from a podcast this morning at
the ancient Romans had no numeral four
zero plus four zero
no you know I think my favorite movie
adaptation of a Bret Easton Ellis novel
has got to be less than zero you asked
for a zero no did you know that
shortstop
Yunel Escobar of the Los Angeles Angels
where's the number zero last four zero
no Nathan Lane he was fantastic in the
producers but by far my favorite Max
Bialystock has got to be Mostel you know
zero yeah yeah you asked for a zero no I
did not ask for a zero thank you very
much Wow all this talking is making me
pretty thirsty yeah me too
I should go for a drink right now yeah
like maybe a Pepsi zero sugar you know a
Pepsi zero sugar would be perfect cuz
it's a bold and refreshing zero calorie
soda with maximum taste Denise what's
going on
Oh Conan I have zero idea real subtle
Denise Oh
you